the movie opens on the 6th of junee 1966
and it is exactly 6:00 a.m. in Rome we
see an American Diplomat Robert Thorns
rushing to a local hospital where his
wife Cathy is delivering a baby
unfortunately when he gets there the
doctor gives him the distressing news
that his baby was still born this leaves
him devastated and he worries about how
he will explain it to his wife at this
moment a priest named father spiletto
suggests that he adopt a newborn boy
whose mother has died today he claims
that it will be a win-win situation for
everyone knowing that his wife will be
crushed by her child's death Robert
readily agrees he's hesitant at first
but then he thinks ah what the hell
what's a little baby swap on a Saturday
night he then takes the baby and
believes him in his wife's arms they
look at him affectionately and name him
Damian cut to a few years later Robert
has just received a promotion I've been
appointed the ambassador to Great
Britain he says she doesn't know what
that means and it sounds lame as hell
hell but he's smiling so it must be good
news so she squeals and hugs him and the
family moves to London when they get
there he shows her the new digs you know
you could be too sexy for the Wayne
housee he says exhibiting a level of
stees that I didn't know existed in the
70s later on the family is walking by
the river the two grown ass adults are
thirsting so hard for each other that
they forget they have a son for a moment
Robert doesn't give a since he
knows the kids a fake but Kathy thinks
he's drowned so they're scared but oh
there he is little demon spawn bastard
some time passes and we see them
celebrating Damian's fifth birthday
everyone is excited and having a good
time let me jum on it Daddy Let Me jump
on it cries the boy which is a weird
sentence suddenly his Nanny stares at a
huge black dog and seems to be
hypnotized she then goes to the rooftop
and tells Daman she loves him before
committing the unthinkable everyone is
horrified by the sight except Daman who
looks at the dog and smiles miles we
then see a photographer named Keith who
is taking pictures of this tragic
incident the following day Robert is in
his office when he is approached by a
priest named father Brennan the priest
insists that he must immediately accept
Christ as his Savior and repent hearing
this Robert becomes confused and doesn't
understand what he wants father Brennan
asserts that he was present on the day
Daman was born and he has seen his real
mother however Robert believes he is
here to blackmail him so he calls
security and ask esorts him away as
father Brendan heads outside Keith shows
up and takes his picture that evening
when he develops the pictures he is
shocked to see a dark spear-like object
over the priest's head in the next scene
a new Nanny named Mrs balock arrives at
Robert's house after a brief
introduction she claims she wants to
meet Daman alone and proceeds to his
room Robert and Cathy are impressed with
her Cathy asks where Robert found the
nanny to which he replies
6669 comom but he's just joking he
didn't find her but neither of them did
so where'd she come from they
immediately approach her and ask how she
got there Mrs balock replies that an
agency saw news of their former Nanny's
death and center the couple is satisfied
with the response and doesn't question
her further she then goes to meet Damian
and says that she has come here to
protect him the little boy doesn't say
anything in response but lets out a
wicked little grin a few days later the
family gets ready for church and Cathy
decides to take Daman there for the
first Time Mrs balock feels he's too
young to understand God's teachings and
shouldn't go however this only irritates
Cathy and she orders her to dress the
kid later while the family heads to
church Daman acts in an unusual manner
he appears to be very anxious almost as
if he's scared of something when they
reach the entrance gate he suddenly
becomes violent Cathy tries to calm him
down but he starts pulling her hair as a
result Robert quickly drives away from
the church prompting the boy to revert
to his normal State I don't blame the
kid church is boring as balls that
evening the couple discusses the
incident and Robert suggests that they
should take their son to the doctor he
feels strange because Daman has never
been sick in his life but Kathy believes
there's nothing strange about him and
he's a healthy boy which is a good thing
later Robert walks to Damian's room but
he comes across the large black dog
outside the door just then Mrs balock
shows up and claims that the dog is here
to keep guard she also asserts that
Damen loves him however this only annoys
Robert and he orders her to find another
shelter for the dog the following day
Kathy takes Daman to a nearby Zoo she
wants him to enjoy the view and learn
about nature they view some giraffes but
giraffes know a stone cold M when they
see one and it's just one of those days
so they bail later they get inside their
car and go to watch some baboons
everything appears to be normal at first
and the mother Sund Duo has a wonderful
time but minutes later the baboons get
angry for some reason and surround the
car they start attacking it fero iously
prompting Damen to scream they swarm the
car their dastardly scrotums hanging
nefariously in mom's face as a result
Cathy steps on the gas and drives away
that evening she shares the traumatic
incident with her husband she asks him
to arrange for her to see a psychiatrist
as she believes she is losing her mind
the next day Robert is watching a rugby
match when father Brennan approaches him
again he claims that his wife's life is
in danger and that he needs to talk to
him he then gives Robert an address and
asks him to come tomorrow if he wants to
save his wife while father Brennan is
leaving we see Keith again who takes his
pictures later when he develops these
photos he again notices the black object
above him how did he get those close-ups
we all know his lens wasn't long enough
the next day Robert meets with Father
Brennan and the two engage in
conversation the latter gets straight to
the point and states that Damen is the
devil's son he also claims that Cathy is
pregnant but Daman will not allow the
child to be born BN according to Brennan
the boy will soon kill her and when he
inherits their wealth he will kill
Robert as well to prevent this he asks
Robert to travel to megido and meet a
man named buen hogen as he is the only
person who knows how to stop the devil
child however Robert thinks that the
father is crazy and warns him never to
bother him again afterward as father
Brennan is leaving for home a heavy
rainstorm ensues he tries to enter a
church for shelter but the doors are
closed suddenly a lightning bolt hits
the Church's Spire which then Falls and
pierces his heart as soon as the father
passes away the storm stops and the
weather goes back to normal the next day
Cathy is in her living room and she is
annoyed by Daman making noises so she
orders Mrs balock to take him away this
seems to upset the boy and he looks at
her furiously before leaving later Cathy
approaches Robert and informs him that
she is pregnant however she is already
fed up with Damian and has decided to
abort the new child this shocks Robert
because father Brennan had already
informed him about the pregnancy moments
later he receives a call from a stranger
who asks him to check the newspaper when
he does he reads the news of Father
Brennan's death leaving him in utter
shock in the next scene Roberts speaks
with Cathy's psychiatrist who informs
him that she is not doing well she often
claims that her son is a devil and also
has Daydreams of Damian hurting her so
given the circumstances the psychiatrist
believes it is not the right time for
her to have a another baby however
Robert refuses to abort the child as he
wants to prove father Brennan's
prediction wrong meanwhile Cathy is
working at home while Daman is playing
on his tricycle something suddenly takes
over him and he crashes into her causing
her to eat crab right over the banister
in the following scene Robert arrives at
the hospital where the doctor informs
him that his wife has survived but lost
her baby this terrifies him as he
realizes that father Brennan's prophecy
is coming true when Robert tries to to
talk to his wife she repeatedly says
that she doesn't want to be killed by
Damian that evening Robert gets a call
from Keith who claims to have important
information about father Brennan later
when they meet Keith shows him pictures
from Damian's birthday where they see a
dark object above the nanny he also
shows pictures of Father Brennan where
there is a similar object after this
Keith displays the autopsy photos of
Father Brennan where they notice the
number 666 on his body which is the
devil's number to find more answers they
head to Brennan's house where they
discover a strange collection of crosses
and Bible sheets they also find his
diary which only contains information
and details regarding Robert's life in
the diary they find that Damian's birth
time is linked to the number 666 since
he was born on the sixth hour of the
sixth day of the sixth month hearing
this Robert gets very upset and blames
himself for adopting Damian and bringing
him into his life he says that it is his
problem and that he will deal with it
himself
however Keith claims that it is his
problem as well he then displays his own
picture where there's the same dark
object over him following this the duo
begins their investigation and travels
to the hospital in Rome where Damian was
born Unfortunately they find out that
the hospital was ruined in a mysterious
fire 5 years earlier and all birth
records were destroyed Robert then asks
a nun about father spiletto the person
who gave him the baby the nun shares
that he is the only survivor of the fire
incident and now resides in a monaster
after that they take the address and
proceed to meet father spaletto when
they arrive they discover that he is
paralyzed and that half of his body has
been severely burned the other priest
informs them that he has gone mute since
the fire incident regardless Robert
approaches him and demands to know about
Damian's real mother father spaletto
doesn't say anything until a bell rings
after which he writes only one word
survey the other priest explains that
survey is an old graveyard in a place
called it skin Robert and Keith
immediately head to the said Graveyard
to unravel the mystery there they
discover the grave of a woman named
Maria whose death date aligns with
daman's birth date when they open the
tomb they discover that it contains the
remains of a female Jackal which proves
that Damen is not a human child
alongside it there is another grave when
they open this tomb they find the
skeleton of an infant whose skull has
been crushed seeing this it finally Dawn
on Robert that his real son was murdered
so that Damian could be adopted just
then they are surrounded and attacked by
several huge black dogs the duo is badly
injured by the hounds but they somehow
managed to escape upon reaching the
hotel Robert immediately calls Cathy and
asks her to come to Rome she is hesitant
because she is still recovering in the
hospital however he claims that it is
not safe for her to be there so she
agrees to come after hanging up Cathy
gets up and starts to change her clothes
but suddenly she senses someone behind
her and she she turns around she notices
Mrs balock staring and smiling at her
moments later Cathy is thrown out of the
hospital window leading to her death in
the next scene Robert receives the
distressing news of his wife's death
this shatters him but he is now hellbent
on stopping the devil child he then
remembers that a few days ago father
Brenan had talked about a man named buen
hogen who can supposedly stop Daman so
he decides to pay him a visit the next
day they travel to megido and meet Bo en
Hogan as they engage in conversation the
latter informs Robert that he has been
waiting for him however before they talk
he sends Keith outside saying he wants
to speak to Robert alone afterward our
good old boy boen hogin gives him some
sacred daggers stating that only with
these can he kill the Devil's Child
Robert is still unsure whether the boy
is the devil so buan Hogan claims that
the kid must have a 666 birth mark
somewhere when Robert claims that he has
never seen such a mark on daman's body
because he figured it would be sus to
look at a naked boy that wasn't really
his buan hogen suggests it might be on
his head hidden by hair after the
meeting ends Keith inquires about what
happened inside Robert explains that
buan Hogan wants him to kill Damian as
he's the Devil's Child however he
refuses to do it since it goes against
his nature he even throws away the
daggers to make his point this leads to
an argument and Keith eventually decides
to carry out the murder himself however
as he tries to retrieve the daggers a
sheet of glass suddenly falls from a
truck and decapitates him that's what
happens when you try to steal buan
Hogan's booty horrified Robert finally
realizes that he has to murder the child
once and for all so he retrieves the
daggers and returns to England upon
reaching the house he spots the black
dog again so he successfully traps him
in the basement and locks the door he
then grabs a pair of scissors and goes
to daman's room to confirm his doubts he
begins cutting the boy's hair and
eventually discovers the number six 666
which horrifies him but before he can do
anything Mrs balock enters the room and
begins attacking him the two get into an
intense fight and fall down the stairs
despite the fall both survive and
continue their fight until Robert
manages to kill her using the dagger
after this he picks up Damien and takes
him to his car the boy begins screaming
and Robert drives at a rapid pace which
soon draws the attention of the police
shortly after Robert arrives at the
church while being pursued by many
police cars He Rush es inside with a
screaming Damian and drags him to the
altar the boy pleads and begs to be
released and for a moment Robert
hesitates however he soon gathers
himself and proceeds to stab the kid
unfortunately at this moment the cops
arrive and shoot him to death in the
final scene we see the double funeral of
Kathy and Robert meanwhile Daman is seen
with Robert's brother who is the
president of the United States where'd
that come from the movie comes to an end
as Damen looks directly at the camera
breaking the fourth wall as only the
devil can and flashes his Sinister
smile subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching